obviously there was a lot of attention  on what was happening inside the Senate  today during commis testimony but I  don't if you knew this through was just  as much Comey excitement happening  outside this Senate building and we  wanted to be there so we sent a camera  crew to check out what was going on  outside during the testimony check it  out there's a guy scalping tickets you  can have two questions guy selling  t-shirts leg DVD vendor we testimony  it's not even over yet merch table with  all kinds of Comey swag bumper stickers  here three four ten where's the pink  tape everybody there's an enterprising  hot dog vendor people doing cosplay  there's Comey Kamala Harris and Marco  Rubio  I love that Rubio  you